covert 19 is complex
it can affect the nervous system leading
to language disorders
strokes and seizures
scientists are still trying to
understand why
75 percent of people hospitalized with
the virus
continue to suffer from secondary
symptoms at least six months after they
recover
many find it hard to function in their
daily lives
researchers hope understanding covert's
impact on the brain
could pave the way for treatment
[Music]
india is breathing a sigh of relief with
daily infections falling
but the havoc from the second wave is
fresh in people's minds
and many patients are still struggling
with the knock-on effects of co-ed
dw's manira chowdhury met deepak agarwa
from delhi after losing 25 kilos
and still very weak deepak is now slowly
trying to get
back to a state of normalcy and the life
he had
before it was disrupted by a severe
cover 19
infection the only issue which came to
my mind is at the age of 60 whether i
will be able to win upon this battle or
not after struggling initially
deepak managed to get admitted to a
hospital when his workplace intervened
of the 50 days he spent there 40 were
spent in the intensive care unit
worst thing which happened is at the end
of the 10th or 12th day
my legs i i found that my legs are not
working
they are they are not the part of my
body i was not able to cope up with the
oxygen mask what they have put and i was
really feeling helpless i said
there is no point in living now because
i can't cope up with this pressure
i left a message to my one of my eldest
cousin brother
that i am not going to survive i think
tomorrow is going to be my last day
each day he could hear people screaming
with pain and discomfort
and each day he saw someone dying
deepak knew he was fighting this
infection at a time when the entire city
was struggling hard to cope with it
it was his two children he says who gave
him the courage he needed
the first feeling that was there with me
24 7 was the fear
fear of losing him you want to return
back to normal
you just want to see those four members
of your family together on the dining
table
kaneka says the experience with their
father and the sights they saw at the
hospital
have made all of them stronger as a
family the post-covet
time is more tougher than the covet time
i'm really finding it very difficult to
cope up with me the recovery time
because it's already one month
it's already one month i'm not able to
walk even the tenth step now so it's
taking
what doctors are telling it will take
six months
one small slow step at a time
he is trying to move towards full
recovery but
with every task still a challenge he
knows it will take a long time
camilla miss koviak is a professor of
cognitive neuropsychiatry and joins us
from copenhagen university hospital
patients like the one in our report can
suffer from cognitive impairment half a
year after recovering from covert
how often does that actually occur
though because the general number we
found was 75
which sounds extremely high
this is a very good question so studies
so far
show quite varying results we've
conducted a study
at university hospital in copenhagen
where we found that
65 percent of people who've been
hospitalized with cobit
continue to show cognitive difficulties
four months after
their hospital discharge this was quite
a small study but still it
is consistent with other studies in the
field so generally studies show
that over half of patients who have been
hospitalized continue to show
cognitive impairments after the recovery
and i guess you won't have that much
data on this but it's worth asking how
much longer
could that sort of thing go on for for
these patients
so we don't know yet because it's a very
new illness and we've only
started recently to study the long-term
effects of kobe on cognition
so based on our study and also other
studies in the field that show
quite consistent findings um
we we think that at least up to six
months
that that these cognitive impairments
last up to six months but
we currently uh conducted follow-up
studies of the same patients
for one year after they got discharged
and i know that other
research groups are doing the same so
hopefully we can give a better
answer to that very soon what sort of
other patterns are
evident in in patients in in your
studies
regarding the patterns of cognitive
impairments
we have found and this is also quite
consistent with other studies in the
field
we found that it's mainly verbal
memories of the ability to remember
words
as well as concentration and planning
abilities
that seem to be affected now it's worth
noting that
the cognitive functions after kobit are
highly variable and actually there is a
large proportion of people who don't
have any
cognitive impairments after they've
recovered from covid
so our findings only you know they're
only representative of people who've
been hospitalized
and even in these people one third or up
to one half or at least one third
i have have no cognitive difficulties
but but those who have cognitive
difficulties they do have
memory problems concentration
difficulties planning difficulties
and this is if we look at the brain this
is mainly related to the frontal lobe
and hippocampus
where the hippocampus is a structure in
the brain that is really
really important for memory formation
and it's also very sensitive to oxygen
starvation
so this could be a biological reason uh
why we
for for these uh difficulties that we
see in these aspects of cognition
and and what are the problems associated
with with these impairments
so again this is something that we're
only just beginning to study
and in our study we found that that the
cognitive impairments
were related to greater degree of
anxiety and depression
and also to problems with functioning at
work
and also poorer quality of life but we
don't really know what the
direction of of these relations
what the direction is so it could be on
one hand that depression
is causing the cognitive problems we
know that from from for example patients
who have depression that they also have
cognitive problems
and so those symptoms can cause
cognitive problems on the other hand we
also know that
if you have cognitive difficulties and
difficulties with functioning in your
daily life
then this can also cause stress and
depression
and anxiety so we don't really know what
the direction of this uh
of this relation is or this association
just that they
seem to coexist and also influence each
other
and what do we know about the prevalence
of these types of complications
of acute illness from covet
so the prevalence of of cognitive
impairments uh differs across
studies so we've conducted studies in in
this study in
in hospitalized people so the more
severe cases
and these findings are not really
applicable to a broader category of
people who've had cobit
we know from several studies that the
severity of illness seems to
be related to a greater risk of
long-term cognitive impairments
so that people with mild illnesses seem
to not be
at at risk so much for for these kinds
of complications
lastly but definitely not least what
sort of therapies or countermeasures can
be taken
this is the million dollar question and
we are all wanting to
study this um so i'm not aware of any
uh treatment that has been shown to be
effective yet based on research
but we're currently looking into this
several research groups that are
investigating this
and also until then until we have an
evidence-based treatment for cognitive
impairments
in these patients clinical psychologists
are applying techniques from other
diseases so for example
traumatic brain injury where people also
have cognitive problems so they use for
example cognitive
rehabilitation techniques and so on so
we will just have to wait
and see whether these methods are also
effective
for cognitive impairments after covet
camilla miss koviak
copenhagen university hospital thank you
very much
thank you and here's a question i've
been asking myself about immunizing
as i had no reaction from either of my
shots
over to derek williams
does not having any side effects after
vaccination
mean you have a weak immune system
this is a great question because it's
about much more than the immune system
it's also about
the psychology of immunization which
i've experienced in an
up close and personal way
i had zero side effects after
either dose of my messenger rna vaccine
my arm didn't even really hurt close
family members
on the other hand were were pretty
uncomfortable afterwards with with
chills and
fever and and headaches and and fatigue
really the whole nine yards they moaned
about the side effects of course but
they were actually almost happy to feel
as lousy as they did
because for them it meant the vaccine
was working
and they were kind of concerned for me
and and maybe even felt
slightly superior because i didn't have
any
um after bracing myself for the worst
i admit that i felt a little let down
and and maybe
maybe even a little bit worried that
that somehow my immune system
was getting something wrong but all the
experts say
i shouldn't worry the truth is we don't
really know
why some immune systems go into
overdrive
briefly after vaccination and others
just seem to kind of coast through it um
the interactions between
all of the different elements of the
immune system are so convoluted
that that immunologists compare it
vividly to
to a ball of spaghetti but as far as we
can tell
experiencing powerful side effects after
vaccination
is mostly about how your own personal
immune system works rather than about
how
effective the vaccine is as a broad rule
of thumb
women and younger people experience side
effects
more often than men and elderly people
do
and and more people have them after the
second shot
then after the first but if like me
you didn't feel a thing afterwards don't
sweat it
all the evidence we have indicates
strongly
that you're just as well protected as
someone
who had a miserable couple of days
thank you derek now i'm feeling better
thanks for watching stay safe
and see you again soon
you